there might actually be a very good
reason for why that kid might prefer the
old CRT and no it's not because retro is
cool it's because CRTs actually have
objective advantages over our modern
televisions that this kid can feel they
have basically zero latency you see when
your modern TV receives a signal from
your console or your cable box or
whatever it does a lot of internal
processing to display that image on its
millions of LEDs those things literally
have powerful computers in them making
this all happen and that processing
takes time so when you press the button
to make your character jump there are
additional milliseconds between you
pressing it and you seeing the character
jump on screen due to that processing
but CRTs it's not really the case
they're straight analog cathode raid
shoes that take the signal and spit it
back out on their fancy gas-based
displays the moment they receive it so
there could very well be a reason why
that kid prefers playing Mario better on
that television he is potentially a
person of Exquisite latency taste